DC Extended Universe fans, rejoice.
Warner Bros. just dropped a new poster promoting
the forthcoming Wonder Woman 1984 film, and
the visual content is rather revealing.
Wonder Woman 1984 is the follow-up to 2017's
Wonder Woman, one of the better-received entries
in Warner Bros.' mostly troubled attempt to
contend with the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
Considering the popularity of the original
film and its leading lady, fans have been
eager to devour this sequel since it was announced
back in 2018.
Sadly, Wonder Woman 1984 has had a pretty
tortured path to the big screen since that
announcement.
Warner Bros. originally slated Wonder Woman
1984 for a December 2019 release, then pushed
that date up to November 2019, then to June
2020.
It just wasn't fair to fans, and then it got
even worse.
"You expect the battle to be fair!
A battle will never be fair!"
Wonder Woman 1984 was recently delayed again,
though by only a few months.
The film is still slated for a summer release,
August 14, 2020, to be precise.
Warner Bros. must be pretty committed to this
ambitious new date, because the studio has
already started pulling out the big promotional
guns, releasing a new poster that reveals
some important information.
If we're being honest with ourselves, any
new poster featuring Gal Gadot as Wonder Woman
seems like a newsworthy development, but this
one has elevated significance.
The latest art from the film is a kaleidoscopic
blast of color centered on Gadot in her Golden
Eagle armor.
The battle suit first debuted in the third
issue of Elseworlds: Kingdom Come, a short
Wonder Woman and Superman crossover comic
story from creators Alex Ross and Mark Waid
that DC ran in 1996.
Unlike Wonder Woman 1984, Kingdom Come takes
place in the near future and concerns the
original Justice League's efforts to thwart
a new generation of meta-humans that pursue
the superhero trade through violent means.
It's in the middle of this conflict that Wonder
Woman busts out her new golden threads.
Since Kingdom Come, many other Wonder Woman
stories have featured the Golden Eagle armor,
including Wonder Woman #144, Our Worlds at
War, and Rise of an Olympian.
Will we see some elements from these popular
comic arcs adapted into the feature film?
Only time will tell.
Given the film's 1984 setting, its plot likely
won't address any of the cliffhangers set
up by 2017's Justice League, but it still
promises to be an entertaining romp full of
action, humor, and heart.
"Have you ever been in love?"
"A long, long time ago."
"You?"
"So many times, yeah.
All the time."
Aside from the new look, the most important
piece of information on the poster is the
confirmation that Warner Bros. plans to forge
ahead with Wonder Woman 1984's late summer
release date.
This is quite the scheduling flex, since the
sequel flick could be pushed back yet again,
depending on when it's safe to return to movie
theaters.
It would be pretty hard to imagine Warner
Bros. letting such an important, and expensive,
film play to empty seats; for now, we can
at least appreciate the studio's optimism.
Fans who have already been burned twice before
by thwarted release dates for Wonder Woman
1984 await the new August drop with cautious
optimism.
Many other big films have been delayed this
year, including the latest James Bond flick,
the live-action Mulan movie, and The New Mutants.
None of those projects have dared to cement
a summer theatrical release in writing, let
alone in expensive marketing materials.
Alongside Gadot's Diana Prince, Warner Bros.
has already confirmed that Wonder Woman 1984
will feature the return of Chris Pine's Steve
Trevor, though just how that will be possible
within the DCEU's internal logic has been
a topic of heated debate.
As you'll remember, Steve seemingly died at
the end of the first Wonder Woman movie.
Also confirmed is Kristen Wiig, who will portray
the villainous Cheetah, and Pedro Pascal as
Maxwell Lord.
Although neither Wiig nor Pascal is featured
in the latest poster for Wonder Woman 1984,
fans are equally eager to see how they bring
their characters to the screen.
With any luck, we'll find out by August 14th.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.